et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
louis aliot bonjour louis aliot merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin maire
de perpignan vice président du
rassemblement national porte parole de
marine le pen et on le voit vous êtes
avec nous en duplex de votre mairie de
perpignan vous remercie d'avoir accepté
cette invitation veux évidemment parler
de la campagne de marine le pen dans
quelques instants mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est l'ukraine triple saut
meyer sommet du g7 sommet extraordinaire
de l'otan conseil européen les
occidentaux qui durcissent encore le ton
face aux russes joe biden veut exclure
la russie du g20 il promet une réponse
de l'otan en cas d'utilisation de l'armé
chimique est ce que vous approuvez cette
fermeté est ce que finalement c'est la
seule réponse à apporter à vladimir
poutine
écouter tout ce qui éloigne du dialogue
et d'un cessez-le-feu rapide
pose quand même question oui évidemment
il faut être ferme à l'égard de cette
agression russe mais il ne faut surtout
pas couper les ponts et le dialogue
parce que sur le terrain la situation
est particulièrement catastrophique et
dans tous les cas quelles que soient les
mesures qui seront prises ou où les
propos qui seront tenus on voit bien
qu'un certain nombre de pays européens
sont assez divisés sur la question et
que le problème de l'énergie
le problème de l'alimentation et est en
train de se poser le problème des
entreprises françaises qu'on y reviendra
tout à l'heure et donc de ce point de
vue là il faut rester extrêmement
prudent ferme ne pas hésiter à dire les
choses à monsieur poutine mais pour
l'instant je veux dire sur le terrain ça
n'a aucun effet il faut donc essayer de
travailler avec des pays qui ont de
l'influencé sur la russie je pense
notamment à la chine évidemment mais à
israël ou même puisqu'elle fait partie
de l'otan à la turquie qui est l'un des
dires des partenaires presque et des
personnes qui dialaw des pays qui
dialogue avec la russie mais tant que ce
problème de l'énergie continuent ce
problème de l'alimentation et ses
problèmes économiques globales je pense
qu'on reste encore dans des positions
des postures et qu'on est très loin
d'avoir réglé le problème donc voilà
c'est un sommet ça fait de la
communication politique je suis pas
persuadé que c'est une grande efficacité
sur le terrain on peut travailler
aujourd'hui avec la chine quand on peut
travailler avec israël ou la turquie où
est ce que la chine est plutôt du côté
de la russie a des intérêts communs avec
la russie dans cette mer
oui mais beaucoup de pays vous savez ont
des intérêts communs avec avec la russie
beaucoup de pays n'ont pas condamné la
russie où l'on condamné timidement et
donc de ce point de vue là il faut
regarder la géopolitique mondiale
l'occident s'est coupé de la russie la
russie s'est coupé de l'occident c'est
un fait je veux dire c'est acté
aujourd'hui et ce sont malheureusement
les ukrainiens qui en paient la note et
et de quelle manière mais ça n'empêche
pas que même entre belligérants il faut
se parler et l'urgence aujourd'hui elle
est une urgence humanitaire
il ya des femmes des enfants qui sont
sur les routes qui fuient les
bombardements
et ce sont ces bombardements qu'il faut
faire arrêter par tous moyens il n'y en
a qu'un aujourd'hui puisque la force
elle est hors de portée contre la russie
aujourd'hui c'est nécessairement la
négociation le dialogue et des mesures
de rétorsion économique pour peu que ces
mesures de rétorsion économique ne se
retourne pas contre nous et ne mettent
pas leur tour en péril notre propre
économie et c'est là tout le jeu de la
mondialisation de l'économie et
aujourd'hui on va regarder mais juste un
bon puisque vous parlez de dialogue
emmanuel macron il à ce dialogue
aujourd'hui avec vladimir poutine va le
demeurer l'ins qui lui-même s'est dit
reconnaissant des efforts que fait
emmanuel macron escoeuilles la raison
est ce que vous aussi vous saluer les
efforts des manuels macron est-ce qu'il
a la bonne méthode
écoutez et qu'ils aient des rapports
avec monsieur poutine
c'est normal de chefs d'état chefs
d'état maintenant je pense qu'il a quand
même peu d influence et qu'il n'est pas
obligé systématiquement à se mettre en
scène dès qu'il admire routine au bout
du fil on a vu le président israélien se
déplacer à moscou où je ne sais où
pouvoir monsieur poutine ça n'a pas fait
les grands titres il n'y a pas eu de
vidéos il n'y a pas eu de mise en scène
je pense que la situation est très
tendue qui n'est pas besoin de beaucoup
communiquer sur le sujet en revanche je
souhaite qu'il y ait ces efforts de
dialogue et si monsieur macron à 7
relation particulière qu'il prétend
avoir avec monsieur poutine tant mieux
mais je ne pense pas qu'il soit en
capacité d'influencé quoi que ce soit en
revanche je répète il ya des pays comme
israël comme la turquie ou comme la
chine tient sûrement les clés de ce day
2 du cessez le feu d'abord du cessez le
feu d'abord et ensuite de la résolution
de ce problème et de cette guerre sur
les sanctions concrètement qu'est ce
qu'on fait et louis aliot est ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin avec des risques
vous l'avez dit de conséquences
notamment sur les français ou est ce
qu'il ne faut pas aller plus loin est ce
que par exemple l'outil vous demandez
aux entreprises françaises de quitter la
russie
moi je crois que c'est un peu
démagogique que je vous le dis
franchement et on peut évidemment avoir
des postures et dire on quitte la russie
mais il faut dire aussi aux français
quel va être le coup quel va être le
coût humain qu'elle va naître le coût
économique et est ce que la place que
nous allons laisser dans ces pays là va
pas être pris par d'autres on a déjà vu
ça dans d'autres pays j'ai aussi lié à
leucan irak pendant très longtemps
on a fait une guerre en irak les
français n'ont rien obtenu et ce sont
les entreprises américaines et qui se
sont installés donc à ce jeu économique
en général les américains sont beaucoup
plus performants que nous alors oui des
sanctions je les dis très certainement
mais sur l'aspect économique des choses
avec le péril notamment de l'énergie
parce que c'est quand même l'énergie qui
cristallise le cet équilibre économique
et encore la france est un peu à l'abri
parce qu'elle est moins dépendante du
gaz russe que ne peut l'être par exemple
l'allemagne de ce point de vue là moi je
demande simplement qu'on ne se précipite
pas qu'on réfléchisse évidemment qu'on
calcule et puis surtout qu'on dise aux
français quelle sera la note parce que
c'est facile de parler devant une caméra
en disant on va sanctionner mais demain
il va falloir dire aux français voilà
combien vous allez payer les denrées
alimentaires voilà combien vous allez
payer l'énergie voilà combien va
augmenter la vie combien mais de combien
va être l'inflation etc et j'ai pas
l'impression aujourd'hui que nous
dirigeants et ce problème à l'esprit il
ya des considérations humanitaires et
des considérations morales que je
comprends très bien mais il ya aussi
notre ville à vis du continent européen
et la vie économique de la france qui
connaît d'extrêmes difficultés il faut
trouver un équilibre entre sanction
entre fermeté mais quand même
préservation de notre intérêt supérieur
national emmanuel macron qui alerte sur
une famine sait ce qu'il a à dire une
famine dans 12 à 18 mois dans plusieurs
pays crise alimentaire sans précédent
qui toucheraient notamment l'egypte le
liban les pays du maghreb et qui
pourrait entraîner forcément une crise
migratoire est ce que si marine le pen
est au pouvoir et que dans 12 à 18 mois
il ya les conséquences qu'on peut
imaginer vous ouvrirez les bras s'est
réfugié
écoutez je pense que c'est totalement
utopique si vous croyez qu'on peut
ouvrir les bras à des dizaines de
millions de personnes qui fuient qui
fuient la misère je pense que c'est
utopique et que ça créera en france et
en europe les conditions de conflits
supplémentaires alors évidemment qu'il
faut regarder attentivement évidemment
il faut tout faire pour éviter cette
famine là dès à présent mais je ne pense
pas comme ça qu'on peut dire a priori
oui venez tout le monde est la bienvenue
parce que nous sommes déjà très en
difficulté pour accueillir la centaine
de milliers de réfugiés où on ne peut
plus que nous avons d'ukrainiens
aujourd'hui on sait déjà débordés par
une immigration clandestine qui
s'étaient installés dans nos ils ont été
incapables de loger à qui on est
incapable de donner du travail et pour
cause il n'a pas pour les français je
vois pas comment demain on pourrait
accueillir des dizaines et des dizaines
de milliers de personnes supplémentaires
sans risque est réellement des conflits
majeurs au sein même de nos propres pays
européens des réfugiés craignant que
vous accueillez un perpignan louis aliot
vous êtes vous est même rendu à la
frontière polonaise pour aller les
chercher d'abord combien en avez-vous
accueilli à perpignan
alors en accueillir 110 et aujourd'hui
même un bus part à la frontière roumaine
et ukrainienne a récupéré 55 de plus à
la demande de la mairie d'odessa
d'ailleurs et c'est des personnes
familles femmes enfants qui seront logés
chez des privés et pris en charge par
des associations ou par des familles
tout simplement qui les accueilleront le
temps du conflit et c'est pour ça que je
vous dis que il est bien accueillir je
pense que c'est de notre responsabilité
mais toujours avoir à l'esprit de
négocier au plus vite cessez le feu
parce que de toute façon cette guerre
pénalise évidemment tout le monde et en
premier lieu ses jus craignait mais ces
ukrainiens ne rêve que d'une chose vous
savez c'est de revenir chez eux parce
qu'ils ont leurs frères leurs pères
leurs fils leurs maris qui est en ce
moment sur le champ de bataille et qui
sont sur le champ de bataille et
j'allais dire il faut que ça s'arrête
vite donc tout ce qui sera entrepris
dans les négociations pour obtenir de la
russie cessez le feu et un dialogue
entre l'ukraine et la russie sera le
bienvenu c'est ce de cela dont il faut
évidemment me parler et c'est cela qu'il
faut appuyer et des réfugiés que vous
vous organiser pour pour accueillir est
ce que comme robert ménard
maire de béziers soutient également de
marine le pen vous avez changé d'avis
sur l'accueil des réfugiés
donc très honnêtement je pense que
robert a sa propre conception vous savez
je pense il a été un président de
reporters sans frontières est peut-être
lui aussi avait une communication quand
il était maire sur le sujet on va dire
très offensive moi je me dis qu'il a
bondi pas sûr que c'est que c'est sa
fonction de maire qui est qui l'a fait
changer d'avis sur ce sujet parce qu'il
a beaucoup appris des réalités du
terrain qui regrettent les positions
qu'il a eu notamment sur les réfugiés
syriens vous c'est pas votre avis
oui non parce qu'on est beaucoup plus
rap et nous par une immigration
clandestine d'origine algérienne et
marocaine or que je sache les marocains
et les algériens ne sont pas en guerre
et je me demande d'ailleurs comment la
france peut tolérer de l'algérie et du
maroc ces flux incessant d'immigration
qui passe par l'espagne sans dire quoi
que ce soit aux autorités parce que je
peux vous dire que paris vient demande à
dire bien au signalement ne dit pas rien
vous le savez louis aliot est aberrante
et logistique de l'impala jeu je ne
savais pas que vous siégez au
gouvernement chère madame mais moi je
peux vous politique d'élimination des
noms mais je peux vous dire que sur le
terrain c'est catastrophique
vous avez des jeunes paumés parce que
faut pas céder jeunes paumés que qui
traversent la frontière et qu'on expulse
ce pas parce qu'on ne peut pas les
expulser parce que l'algérie pendant
longtemps fermé ses frontières et le
maroc aussi mais pour le coup ils sont
dans nos rues mais je veux dire ils sont
voilà ces îles sont livrés m ou pris en
charge par des associations qui font
leur travail du humanitaire mais si je
trouve que c'est assez catastrophique
parce que la plupart du temps pas tous
évidemment ils sont pris en charge par
des mafias locales intégrées à des
réseaux de la drogue ou de prostitution
et moi je trouve ça humainement
dramatique et économiquement dangereux
voilà et qu'on ne pourra pas tenir
longtemps notamment au niveau des villes
par rapport à cette immigration là là
nous sommes avec des réfugiés des
réfugiés aux européens des réfugiés
femmes et enfants dans un jeu 1-2 les
hommes parce que d'accord oui mais c'est
important de le dire et je pense que les
français l'ont vu on a compris on va
passer à un autre sujet d'actualité
c'est la corse aujourd'hui se tiennent
les obsèques d'yves en colonne qui a été
condamné pour l'assassinât du préfet
erignac qui a été tuées en prison par un
détenu un radicaliser est ce que vous
comprenez le choix de l'exécutif corse
de mettre les drapeaux en berne pendant
cette période de deuil
d'abord
systématiquement quand on parle de cette
affaire moi je pense surtout à la
famille du préfet erignac
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est le scandale qui est un
scandale d'état comment dans une prison
française un détenu aussi sensible que
monsieur colonna peut être laisser comme
ça à la merci d'un islamiste d'une
personnalité particulièrement
dangereuses sans surveillance autant de
temps qui conduit à ce drame et qui
conduit évidemment à la colère de nos
compatriotes corses ça je dois dire que
c'est quelque chose que je n'arrive
toujours pas à comprendre j'ai bien
entendu les explications du directeur
général de l'administration
pénitentiaire mais très honnêtement il
n'a convaincu personne est ce que j'ai
les indications du pont d'amitié est ce
que vous attendez des explications
d'eric dupond-moretti clé silencieux
pour le moment sur le sujet mais il est
très silencieux oui c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire est il encore sa pause de
kmm évidemment un problème par rapport à
sa mission est de ce point de vue là
c'est incompréhensible maintenant je ne
comprends pas non plus
l'exécutif corse qui gère l'île par
rapport à ses drapeaux en berne voilà
c'est je pense
un manque quand même de respect par
rapport à la famille du préfet erignac
et je pense que c'était pas nécessaire
voilà je pense qu'il faut respecter le
deuil de la famille colonna ça c'est
évident je pense qu'il faut respecter
nos amis corses eux car je rappelle
qu'ils ont été très nombreux au moment
de cet assassinat pour condamner ce
crime à l'époque et ce n'est pas la
peine de jeter de l'huile sur le feu ce
n'est pas la peine de faire agrandir les
fractures qui existe déjà entre le
continent et la corse kg dizaine de
villes sont situées juste lui à léo qui
jettent de l'huile sur le feu
mais je pense que pendant longtemps le
gouvernement n'a pas trop écouter les
revendications légitimes des familles
des détenus corses ya aucune raison que
les détenus corses ne puisse pas exercer
leur peine sur l'île ça moi je pense que
c'est déjà une nécessité et de l'autre
côté la facture de cet exécutif gants
corps ce qui petit à petit j'allais dire
se prend ses distances avec notre pays
avec notre république ce qui n'est pas
très sain car la corse c'est la france
la france évidemment à sosa plus grande
nécessité de maintenir la corse à la
france et je ne vois pas pourquoi on
échangerait qu'il y ait un statut
particulier il existe déjà et c'est
d'ailleurs des nationalistes ou des
indépendantistes comme les corses eux
qui sont qui le gère donc que c'est
mispo red bull pression
oui oui mais c'était un qui sont aux
manettes et c'est leur bilan qu'il faut
regarder qu'il faut discuter aller plus
loin dans quoi je ne sais pas c'est il
faut regarder quelles sont les
revendications mais je pense que par
rapport à un au crime du préfet erignac
par rapport à cette abominable crime
aussi assassinat dans une prison
française il vaut mieux quand même joué
l'apaisement ne pas jeter de l'huile sur
le feu et ne pas faire de promesses
inconsidérées et quand je vois que
monsieur d'arman et s'est précipité en
proposant tout de suite un statut
d'autonomie sans en parler à personne
sans mettre autour de la table d'autres
personnes que ceux qui le demandent de
là-bas en corse et je trouve que c'est
un peu cavalier et que ce n'est pas un
faire preuve de responsabilité dans une
question sensible d'un territoire
particulièrement fragiles de notre pays
et de notre république lui allez on va
parler de la campagne de marine le pen
marine le pen qui était invité hier du
20 heures de tf1 sur la réforme des
retraites on sait que c'est un point un
peu floue de votre programme vous allez
nous éclairer à la 10 40 annuités avec
un départ à 40 ans 42 annuités pour avec
un départ à 60 ans par dont 42 annuités
pour un départ à 62 ans est ce que
clairement vous pourrez vous pouvez nous
dire si marine le pen est président de
la république qu'elle sera l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite
écoutez il sera à 60 ans pour ceux qui
commencent leur carrière
très tôt et qui ont 40 annuités et 62
ans pour les autres je pense qu'il ya
des encore une fois il faut quand même
tenir compte de la fonction est dû mais
des métiers des gens quant à monsieur
macron qui parle comme ça de 65 ans il
croit que il ya des gens sur les
chantiers qui peuvent travailler jusqu'à
65 ans il ne croit vraiment où il sait
pas de quoi on parle
moi j'ai vu toute ma vie dans ma propre
famille des gens de travailler dans les
bâtiments et ils croient comme ça qu'on
peut durer 65 ans sous le vent du poids
en étendant les intempéries en ayant des
conditions particulièrement difficiles
de travail tout choisir il sera précédé
la technocratie si de la technocratie
tout ça s'est décidé de choses dans un
bureau sans connaître réellement la
dureté des choses et de ce point de vue
là d'ailleurs les français ne s'y
trompent pas puisque je crois 70 % des
français sont opposés à la retraite à 65
ans ils veulent maintenir cette retraite
évidemment dès que c'est possible en
l'occurrence à 60 ans et après 40
annuités
car les annuités pèse autant que l'âge
de la retraite évidemment et c'est de
cela dont on parle dans ce débat
présidentiel marine le pen qui est donné
pour le moment second tour dans les
sondages à 16 jours maintenant du
premier tour mais il ya une dynamique de
jean luc mélenchon dans ces sondages est
ce que pour vous jean luc mélenchon de
manas la présence de marine le pen au
second tour
non je ne le pense pas et d'ailleurs il
ya deux dynamiques il ya une dynamique
pour marine le pen qui a encore pris de
points dans un trois points dans l'autre
et monsieur mélenchon aussi mais je ne
pense pas qu'il soit en capacité de
rassembler plus que évidemment le score
que fera marine le pen au soir de ce
premier tour je note aussi petit à petit
la baisse de monsieur macron ce qu'il
faut maintenant en ce qui nous concerne
c'est faire comprendre un certain nombre
de français que le vote pour madame
pécresse ou que le vote pour monsieur
zemmour aujourd'hui est un vote
malheureusement qui ne sert plus à rien
le débat a eu lieu on a vu les positions
des uns et des autres maintenant il faut
battre monsieur macro pour battre
monsieur macro pour changer de politique
il n'y a qu'un seul vote aujourd'hui
qu'ils soient un vote utile c'est le
vote en faveur de marine le pen et je
pense que toutes les émissions qu'elle a
fait tous les retours que moi j'ai sur
le terrain par rapport à ses positions
aux programmes qu'elles défendent par
rapport aux efforts qu'elle a fournis
pendant cette campagne pour prouver
qu'elle était à la hauteur de l'enjeu eh
bien ils sont entrain j'allais dire de
payer parce que beaucoup de français
aujourd'hui se tourner vers nous nous
pose des questions et je pense nous
rejoindront dans cette dernière ligne
droite pour accentuer encore cette
dynamique en vue du deuxième tour parce
que rien n'est joué je ne fais pas
partie de celles et ceux qui pensent que
monsieur maquereau a gagné et que
l'élection est plié je pense que l'on
peut tout à fait battre monsieur macro
et que tous les gens qui ont eu à subir
la politique de monsieur macron depuis
cinq ans se retrouveront nécessairement
dans les urnes pour ce deuxième tour et
qui lui a une chance historique de
changer de politique de changer de
président et de changer de système tout
simplement pour favoriser j'allais dire
une prospérité économique pour défendre
la sécurité et pour défendre notre
identité vous dites le vote pourrait
aisément aujourd'hui ce n'est plus un
vote utile la campagne s a été assez
tendu entre marine le pen et eric
zemmour il ya eu des départs de votre
parti vert irisé mots on va pas y
revenir est ce que vous pouvez vous
rejoindre eric zemmour et marine le pen
au soir du premier tour si l'un des deux
est présent au second
écoutez je ne passe là aujourd'hui je
pense que madame le pen sera présente
marine sera présente au au deuxième
quart alors si c'est ça la vidéo est ce
que vous appelez eric zemmour à vous
rejoindre au soir du premier tour ou
pour vous la campagne vous a rendu
irréconciliables
non moi je pense qu'il faut d'abord
parler aux électeurs qui ont voté eric
zemmour il ya un certain nombre de
personnages évidemment autour de lui qui
sont partis de chez nous à nous insulte
en a qui sera très certainement
difficile de parler mais encore j'ai à
dire ça ne tient qu'à moi c'est un
marine aussi à faire ses choix et moi ce
n'est que mon opinion mais n'en demeure
pas moins qu'il ya des gens qui
s'apprêtent à voter eric zemmour au
premier tour et cela au deuxième tour
devront faire un choix est ce choix
nécessairement il se fera en fonction de
la candidate la plus proche de leurs
idées et la candidate en l'occurrence la
plus proche de leurs idées au deuxième
tour ce sera évidemment marine le pen et
ce seront aux cadres et ce sens parlant
aux cadres de reconquête de prendre
leurs responsabilités et de discussions
le n'y aura pas de discussion quand il
fut par exemple en 2017 avec nicolas
dupont aignan eric zemmour par exemple
vous ne proposerait pas le poste de
premier ministre
écoutez je pense que cette élection
c'est l'histoire d'un candidat ou d'une
candidate avec un peuple et des
électeurs et qu'il faut s'adresser
directement à eux je pense que tout ce
qui peut apparaître comme calcul
politicien négociations de couloir tout
ce qu'on a pu voir d'ailleurs chez
monsieur zemmour avec un certain nombre
de gens qui sont partis de chez nous
pour négocier des places tout ça les
français ne veulent plus de moi ce que
je souhaite c'est qu'on parle aux
électeurs qu'on parle au peuple français
dans ce que le peuple français par dont
il ya des gens de droite et il ya aussi
des patriotes de gauche et il faudra
s'adresser à tout le monde pour
rassembler tout le monde et de ce point
de vue là je fais confiance à marine qui
fait sa déjà très bien et qui j'espère
accentuera ce mouvement au deuxième tour
parce que il faut aller au-delà de 50%
est dans cette dynamique là il y aura
des gens de tous les horizons politiques
et pas seulement d'un camp politique
carette au président de la france c'est
être président de tous les français et
pas seulement green gestion d'une partie
ou d'un groupe une dernière question lui
à lire sur les législatives d'abord vous
pourriez être candidat aux législatives
non je ne pourrais pas être candidat
parce que je suis maire de perpignan que
toute façon il ya la loi sur le cumul
des mandats on vous quitterez mange
ribéry pour l'assemblée nationale que
j'ai déjà fort à faire à la mairie de
perpignan et donc je ne serai pas
candidat aux élections législatives
évidemment je soutiendrai mais candidats
ici et est ce que là il pourrait y avoir
des accords avec eric zemmour voir avec
les as l'air
et je pense que le président doit
obtenir une majorité parlementaire et
que pour obtenir une majorité
parlementaire et bien il faut parler à
des partenaires et dans ce cadre là très
certainement il faudra pour législatives
parler notamment effectivement où elle
est aussi parce que ils sont une
composante importante du paysage
politique français pour une partie
opposée à monsieur macro mais vous avez
dit a vu que pour l'autre partie il
s'apprête déjà à voter pour monsieur mc
ren et cela j'allais dire n'ont aucun
intérêt il faut s'intéresser aux autres
et moi je vois sur le terrain beaucoup
de cadres des verts qui me disent mais
laissons passer les présidentielles et
on verra après pour regarder une
majorité législative et donc continuons
cette élection présidentielle et puis on
verra après merci louis aliot merci
beaucoup d'avoir été à transiter maire
de perpignan vice président du
rassemblement national et porte parole
de marine le pen merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous
[Musique]